su cirujano realizará un procedimiento
de injerto de piel para reparar la piel
muy dañada o ausente transplantando piel
sana a la zona donde se encuentra la
piel dañada
la piel tiene tres capas principales la
epidermis
la dermis
y la hipodermis o capa subcutánea que
contiene grasa vasos sanguíneos y
nervios
la piel es el órgano más grande del
cuerpo cumple muchas funciones
principales que incluyen cubrir el
cuerpo físicamente proteger el interior
del cuerpo
y regular la temperatura corporal
y proporcionar el sentido del tacto
en algunos casos su piel puede dañarse
tanto que no sanará adecuadamente es
posible que su médico recomiende un
procedimiento de injerto de piel para
curar muchas enfermedades de la piel que
incluyen una herida que no sana una
quemadura severa una úlcera cutánea una
biopsia de piel una herida quirúrgica
grande o una infección cutánea antes de
su procedimiento es posible que reciba
anestesia general o local
si el cirujano utiliza su propia piel
sana llamada auto injerto es posible que
él o ella crea un injerto de piel
parcial o un injerto de piel de grosor
completo dependiendo de la profundidad
de la piel que el injerto debe cubrir
después de limpiar el área de piel sana
llamada sitio donante el cirujano
utilizará un instrumento llamado de
hematoma para extraer capas muy delgadas
de piel creando un injerto de piel
parcial
para injertos de piel de grosor completo
el cirujano utilizará un bisturí para
extraer todas las capas de piel del
sitio donante
una vez que sus cirujanos determine el
tipo de injerto de piel que necesita él
o ella limpiará el área de piel dañada y
extirpar a cualquier tejido muerto o
enfermo su cirujano colocará el injerto
de piel sobre la herida y lo mantendrá
en su lugar con puntos luego el cirujano
aplicará una pomada al injerto y lo
cubrirá con gasa
finalmente es posible que el cirujano
utilice vendas para asegurar el injerto
y ejercer presión mientras el injerto se
adhiere a la piel que lo rodea después
del procedimiento es posible que el
médico le administre medicamentos para
el dolor vía intravenosa u oral y
posiblemente deba incrementar la
cantidad de calorías y proteínas de su
dieta para ayudar a que su piel sane
durante los primeros días posteriores al
procedimiento deberá proteger la zona
del injerto de piel deberá mantener el
sitio donante seco mientras sana también
debe evitar actividades enérgicas hasta
que su médico le indique que puede
realizarlas y es posible que deba
visitar a su médico varias veces para
que limpie la herida y la cubra con una
venda a medida que su herida sana